a fifth election in less than four years
israel's prime minister is to disband
the knesset after failing to maintain
his coalition but will a new vote make a
difference and what impact does
political instability have on israel and
the palestinians this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
daddy nabogeta keeping benjamin
netanyahu out that's what the eight
parties making up the israeli government
had in common but it hasn't been enough
to keep a government divided on nearly
everything from collapsing defections
and inability to pass legislation and
disagreements with arab israeli
coalition allies over israeli attacks on
the occupied aqsa mosque compound all
leading to a disillusion of parliament
after only a year in office
so a date in october has been put
forward to hold a general election the
fifth in three and a half years
according to netanyahu the winds have
changed and his hardline likud party has
already begun courting members of the
knesset for his possible return bernard
smith has this report
for a year benjamin netanyahu has been
working to bring down the coalition that
ousted him from power and he's managed
it by blocking the normally automatic
renewal of a bill that extends israeli
law into the settlements now netanyahu
sees a path back to the prime minister's
office
i intend to form a strong national
steady government i think the atmosphere
change i can feel it i hear from the
people
we now want the real change we want to
return the state of israel to the place
it deserves and i intend to do it
together with my friends the outgoing
eight party coalition was the most
unusual in israeli history made up of
the hard right liberals and palestinian
israelis from the arab list they came
together to get rid of netanyahu but
they claim other achievements
i must say that i'm sad because the
government was a pretty good government
with cooperation between arabs and
jewish representatives in the knesset
with very good
ministers especially in environment
health
international cooperation
and
i think that this government
[Music]
was very good for the citizens of israel
now the latest poll suggests benjamin
netanyahu could win 60 of the 120 seats
up for grabs in the knesset the election
won't be held until towards the end of
october until then yaya lapid is
israel's interim prime minister
let's now bring in our guest joining us
from west jerusalem is gil hoffman who
is the chief political correspondent at
the jerusalem post
in warsaw maron rappaport is writer and
editor at new site local call and also
in west jerusalem gideon rahat who's a
senior fellow at israel democracy
institute and chair of political science
at hebrew university of jerusalem
welcome to the program thanks so much
for your time gil hofmann i'll begin
with you so waiting in the wings there's
benjamin netanyahu who's of course
currently on trial for corruption
charges what are his chances to once
again become prime minister
pretty likely as it stands right now
he his liquid party is doing the best in
the polls
right now he does not yet in the polls
have a blocking majority
to be able to form a government
all the parties that succeeded in
ousting him last time would have to
cooperate successfully again
in order to prevent them from being able
to form a government
the government just fell apart fell
apart because
they had too few seats it was and it was
too narrow a government and they
couldn't afford to have the rebellions
that inevitably came
but the downfall of the government
wasn't an indictment of the diversity
the diversity can succeed and it was
very impressive we had right-wing
centrists and left-wing together
very orthodox and very anti-orthodox
together
and for the first time ever an islamist
arab party and that they can all join
forces again
at least to prevent netanyahu from
forming the government
if not
to allow them to form another one
themselves all right stand by for a
second let's bring in gideon do you
agree with what gil has to say i mean
some polls are showing that uh
netanyahu's likud party would would once
again be the largest in parliament going
forward but could he put together a
coalition
if you look at the polls it looks like
we're going to see the same thing again
no
majority for
netanyahu to form a government
majority clear majority for the israeli
right but no majority for the supporters
of netanyahu
so you know when you look at these you
you imagine that we might have
another government like the one that we
have right now or the previous one
with you know uh
two uh uh with rotation or something
like this
or we might have another elections but
that's again it is based on the current
polls and these polls uh the election
results are very sensitive
to the uh ability of specific parties to
pass the electoral threshold of 3.25
percent of the vote okay maroon uh
netanyahu
i just want to um focus on him for a
second i mean he we've seen him on
israeli media at least he's come out
he's looking quite bullish on television
in his own words he's saying that the
winds have changed how popular do you
think he remains with right-wing
it's
israelis
very very popular uh
there's no doubt about it uh maybe some
people thought that after the the the
the trial will begin then his popularity
uh will will win the uh will go down and
there will be opponents from within the
liquid party this uh did not happen and
i think he's quite popular whether he
will get this 61 majority this is a
question we have to remember that in the
last elections the polls were more
favorable to the right wing than uh
than the actual results but now got
better in the polls than he got in the
actual results so it's very open
okay i see gil um i just want to take
you up on something you said a moment
ago where you said the coalition was
diverse and you believe that diversity
can succeed but you know a lot of people
say that it was the fragility of the
coalition
under bennett that that led to all of
this are you surprised by this turn of
events or have you expected it
i was surprised when
the cohesive coalition started crumbling
on the third of april
until then it looked like that they all
had the same goal in mind which included
keeping nathaniel out of power he was
seen as the glue
that kept them together
but netanyahu ran a campaign of scare
tactics
against the right-wing members of canada
they were part of the coalition and two
of them cracked
you had the former coalition chairwoman
who was
faced
tremendous pressure from netanyahu's
people he paid people demonstrate
outside her home uh to heckle her
children on the way to school
it got to be absolutely untenable
uh it's the job of the opposition to
bring the government down and he now
succeeded he deserves credit for that
and and gideon i mean the final straw
came when a bill allowing jewish
settlers in the occupied west bank to
live under israeli jurisdiction uh while
many palestinians live under the rules
of military occupation was defeated in
parliament that is what led to the
downfall of this government what does
this tell us about the state of play in
israel when this settler law which
normally would enjoy broad support in
parliament and has been renewed over the
past couple of decades failed to pass
this time around
this was a show that
netanyahu and his
[Music]
his camp
were determined to
to go with all of the power
to house the government because
this law is a classic law for the
settlers for the israeli right and they
were ready to go against their own
interests in order to oust this
government
yeah maron can you weigh in on this
because it is pretty it's outstanding
that that netanyahu who despite his
ideological support uh for extending
israeli law to west bank settlers told
his likud parties to vote against this i
mean how shocking is that
not i don't think it's shocking i think
what happened and i uh here i i
i personally predicted that the
government will fall in june
i was quite uh sure it will because uh
the government pretended the the benefit
government pretended that we can freeze
the palestinian issue uh for
three years four years uh time now uh
the palestinian are not part of the deal
uh they are not ready to be freezed
and the situation did deteriorate and
disaffected the government and as
regarding the law
we have to understand that what happened
now is that israeli
society jewish israeli society is unable
to reach a consensus and as a part of
this
all kind of issues that regularly went
unnoticed like this law just come up
and all the contradiction within israel
just come up and this is one a great
example of how a law that was unnoticed
for 55 years
makes the government fall so maron to
put it simply then would it be fair to
say that the coalition government
ultimately collapsed over the
palestinian
conflict and and the occupation
i think phil i'll come to you in a
second i see you shaking your head i i i
think
i think yes i think this is what led the
coalition to fall uh uh
specifically it was this law but the
whole uh the freeze try to freeze the
palestinian issue and trying to avoid it
just put more and more pressure on the
government
from all sides from the more right-wing
side people in venice party and from the
left
from
a bus
party and these two just couldn't
live under this pressure from the right
and from the left and just the
government collapsed i think there's no
other reason for the government to
collapse than the palestinian issue all
right i see both gil and gideon want to
weigh in on this so gil over to you
first and gideon i'll give you a chance
to respond as well
i've worked at the knesset for 24 years
and i don't remember the last time the
palestinians were even brought up
they certainly weren't brought up by any
of the people rebelling inside the
coalition not even when the ram party
the air muslim party started rebelling
they it wasn't really about the
palestinians either
um
this bill is a bill that's not
controversial it hasn't some things that
are very important to right-wing people
and some things that are very important
to left-wing people um and it always
passed unanimously or only the air
members of connected voting against it
it was never controversial in any way
this was something that was just
exploited because it had a deadline on
it it had to pass by next thursday the
30th of june
that the opposition said well we're not
going to vote for it and with since an
arab party couldn't vote for the
coalition had no majority for it
and the opposition smartly exploited
that in order to bring the government
down
but it had nothing to do with the
palestinians who will remain irrelevant
in israeli politics until after they
have their election that they have a
leader who's 86 years old
who doesn't have the support of his
people and that's i guess for another
show all right gideon over to you i mean
this is what ayman audi had to say who
of course you know is the knesset member
head of the arab joint list he wrote on
twitter its efforts to keep the
occupation in place are what brought the
government down as much as the
government did everything to to ignore
it
you you
agree with that or or what's your
response
no i mean
israeli politics in the last year few
years the last
four election rounds and probably the
next one
is only about one
main issue the
continuation of
uh the rule of benjamin netanyahu or
the end of his rule that's all
all of the other things
including very important other issues
are secondary because if the territories
are where the issues we would have
a right-wing majority stable right-wing
majority of
seats
something like this if if this was the
main issue so
i think that that it's uh maybe the
palestinian issue is still there maybe
the palestinian issue was used but the
palestinian issue will always be the
elephant in the room will it not
well the the palestinian issue is a
non-issue for the current
government because it cannot be an issue
it i think
if it was the main issue so we would
have a coalition we would have a
coalition of 70 72
members of the right wing that support
with different nuances the idea of of
greater israel so i think that the main
issue right now is the rule of netanyahu
rather than the
palestinian issue well okay let's let's
just bring in maryland for just a moment
because uh we were mentioning the the
arab lists um just a moment ago and and
amen all day maron one question that
leaves people wondering is what the arab
parties will do next because on the one
hand you have the the ram which made
history as you know a year ago the first
air party to join a ruling coalition on
the other hand you have the arab joint
list
how do you see
that going forward
that's a big question i don't have the
answer i think the question the the real
answer is the percentage of
participation
if uh participation among the
palestinian
citizens of israel will remain low as it
did in the last election
something like 50 or even below that
then that gives a great chance for
netanyahu to win
if uh uh on the other hand the the
participation rate will go
up as it did in september
uh uh
in april uh 2020
then we will have the joint list maybe
on 15 or both parties
together on 15
seats and this will change completely
the political map uh i think what
happened
in the last year
uh uh at the moment it seems that the
participation will remain low because
there's this uh in going
in fights between the palestinian
parties uh the islamic party on the one
hand and the jointlies from the other
so i think the result will be maybe that
the participation will remain low but i
want just a quick remark if the issue uh
to what was said before if the issue was
only netanyahu or not netanyahu then the
government would have stayed
then there's no reason there was no
reason for the government to fall but
all the crisis that we have
during this last year crisis about the
naturalization law and uh
and of course now all the crisis were
connected to the palestinian issue and
all the attacks by the right-wing was on
the fact that terror
supporters are in the government so to
say that the palestinian issue is
non-existent i think it's it's it's uh
uh ignoring the political uh reality
okay uh gil uh talk to us about the
procedure going forward the knesset has
already voted preliminary uh to disperse
itself 110 to zero from what i
understand it still must pass three more
times next week is that correct what is
the procedure
correct so
next monday next wednesday at the latest
the knesset will have the three more
readings there's a fight over which
committee will deal with it whether it's
a committee that's led by a loyalist of
bennett or or or someone who rebelled
against bennet uh there are those in
likud who still want to try to form a
government with a corinthian asset they
look at the current knesset c72
right-wing members of knesset uh another
eight from the blue and white party of
benny ghance who happens to despise the
proposed prime minister yay or lapid
and think maybe they can prevent this
election from happening and that
speculation will continue
until next week when still the
overwhelmingly likely scenario is that
an election
would be initiated
that would be held
as
that he will be most probably meeting
with the u.s president joe biden when
joe biden visits next month and this is
what the state department has said um i
don't expect political development in
israel will have implications for what
we're seeking to accomplish together
with our israeli partners what is israel
hoping to get out of this visit
this visit is uh you know it's a visit
of uh
one head of the country with another so
for the state of israel
this would uh
signify
a kind of uh
continuation of the uh close
relationship with the united states in
general but i also suspect that the
american current
administration
would not
be
so sad
if
if biden's visit would give some
type of sign that they
support
lapid and his side of the political map
what is your take on the u.s president's
visit to israel next month ahead of uh
you know whilst the country is in
political turmoil
i think i think uh it was originally uh
one of the reasons for this visit is to
really uh reinforce uh bennett's
position and bennett's uh
government now that the bennett's
government is falling i think
uh the us will be very happy to see
repeat this prime minister help him uh
to to win uh the next election they
prefer him uh for bennett then it was
you know they were forced to accept him
as an alternative to netanyahu i think
they will try and help repeat this is
not what they meant at the beginning but
i think they will try to help his
position and strengthen his position in
the israeli public gail what will um
jerry lapid bring to the table as
interim prime minister and and from what
i understand i mean going forward the
the dispersing of the knesset not only
holds a series of economic reforms but
also no nominations of senior officials
can take place in the country for
example
the next military chief of staff so how
does all this affect israel sort of
internally
internally it puts the government in
paralysis again which it was through the
first four elections
uh only this time instead of having
netanyahu presiding over it and having
an interest in going to election after
election after election
you have uh lapid there and then
netanyahu has an interest in ousting him
as fast as possible
meanwhile lupita is moderate and that is
something that the world including
president biden would want to work with
but they could easily screw up
let's not forget joe biden had a visit
here as vice president in which he made
a big deal about building in an
ultra-orthodox neighborhood in jerusalem
surrounded by ultra-orthodox
neighborhoods in jerusalem and acted as
if a new settlement had been built deep
in the west bank that would have
prevented the creation of a palestinian
state uh him making such a big deal
about that
ended up making it a lot harder for the
americans to move the peace process
forward after that if he insists on
taking steps to show that they're
even-handed and helping the palestinians
he might as well just give a vote
thousands of votes
to netanyahu he would give him such a
boost
so biden has to be very very careful in
what he says and what he does here
because everything will be very very
scrutinized because it's happening
during an election campaign and not only
that speaking of the time in gideon i'll
bring you in um the timing of all of
this coming of course as
israel has ratcheted up tensions with
iran syria
lebanon
what do you make of that
um
well
this is uh
on the one hand we have all of these uh
possible conflicts and actually the
conflict is not with lebanon it's with
the hezbollah that is
the strongest force within lebanon and
probably the proxy of iran
but all of these things are on
there on the one hand on the other hand
israel also have
some
[Music]
i wouldn't some peace agreement and some
better relationship with other countries
so things are going
in the middle east all the time some
people are becoming closer to each other
some people are
far from each other i mean this is the
life this is the balance of power the i
mean who would believe that uh
that 50 years ago israel and iran were
the closest friends in the middle east
together with uh turkey
so i mean
this is uh something that
is part of balance of power in the world
and also in the area and this is
something that israelis are living with
for decades actually i think that israel
is
but much better off
with its relationship with many uh
middle eastern countries then it was uh
decades before i think many middle
eastern countries have
come to expect the fact that israel is
here to stay and then they try to uh to
have relationship and maybe even try to
influence uh the israeli-palestinian
conflict in more diplomatic ways all
right on that note we'll have to leave
it there thank you so much for joining
us gil hoffman maron rappaport and
gideon rahat we appreciate your time
thank you for watching you can see the
program again anytime by visiting our
website aljazeera.com for further
discussion go to our facebook page
that's facebook.com forward slash aj
inside story join the conversation on
twitter our handle is aj inside story
for myself and the whole team here in
doha thanks for watching bye for now
[Music]
you